we'd like to consider torques on a body
let's draw an arbitrary body and let's
consider a point s that we're about to
calculate the tort now we know that
forces on the body can be both internal
and external and we'd like to show that
all internal torques will cancel in
pairs the way we'll do that is suppose
we pick a object we'll label it with
mass M I and another object we'll label
that with mass M J these are small mass
elements in the body and we'd like to
know something about the internal forces
now let's make the assumption and this
is the key property that the force due
to this interaction between J and the
eigth particle pointing that way and
here's the Newton's third law pair that
these forces lie are directed along the
line connecting the two bodies with this
assumption will now show that the torque
on due to these two internal forces you
know the third law pairs will cancel so
let's calculate that out so we draw our
vector from our s I and our other vector
R s J and now in position to add these
two torques so we have the torque on s
due to this pair is equal to the sum of
our s I cross f ji plus r s that's an R
make sure we get that right we have our
s J cross F I J now the third law pair
says F ji is equal to minus F I J and so
if we substitute let's put the minus
sign over here we get our si minus R s J
cross F
J I now let's look at this vector in
particular we can draw it again over
here just to see it
here's s here is RS I here is the vector
R s that's our s J and we want to now
consider the vector R s I minus r SJ
notice that this vector is directed
along the lines connecting the I in the
J particle and we've made an assumption
that F J I is also along that line so
these two vectors in this particular
case are either parallel or antiparallel
and hence the torque due to the sum of
these internal forces cancel in pairs
and this means we only need to address
the torque due to external forces that
are acting on individual elements in a
body